This is the largest protest in Poland
since the fall of communism
more than 30 years ago.
Hundreds of thousands are protesting,
in cities across the country,
because the party in power here is on the verge
of eliminating a woman’s right to an abortion.
At the heart of these protests are young women:
those who are the most
threatened by the new ruling.
But there are many, many others too.
And that’s because these protesters
aren’t just concerned
about the future of abortion rights in Poland.
They’re worried about the future
of the country itself.
In the late 1980s, Poland got rid
of its decades-long communist regime.
Soon, it became a thriving democracy,
with a strong catholic identity.
It also passed one of the strictest laws on abortion in all of Europe.
Under the law, women were only allowed
to have an abortion under three circumstances:
if the pregnancy was a threat
to the health of the mother,
if it was the result of incest or rape,
or if the fetus had severe
and irreversible abnormalities.
The law has remained this way
for nearly 30 years.
And today, it makes Poland an outlier in Europe,
where virtually every other country allows
abortions under a broad range of circumstances.
But some in Poland thought
those strict laws still weren’t enough.
In 2015, Poland elected the right-wing party
Law and Justice into power.
Shortly after, the party leader said:
"Very close to the totalitarian way of thinking,
as far as women's health, women's rights,
and women's personhood is concerned."
In 2016, the party backed legislation
to eliminate all three legal paths to abortion.
The legislation proposed imprisoning
women seeking abortions,
and doctors who performed them,
for up to five years.
They would even investigate miscarriages.
"This is something that is incredible, you know?
It really turns us back to the Middle Ages.
The limitation of human rights went far too far."
Thousands of women took to the streets,
pushing back against the law,
in what were called the Black Protests.
In the face of this opposition,
the legislation was withdrawn.
Poland would still have one of the strictest abortion laws in Europe,
but not a total ban.
But instead of giving up on the abortion ban,
Law & Justice started dismantling
the country’s ability to oppose one.
In Poland’s democracy,
some legislation passed by Parliament
is sent to the Constitutional Tribunal,
to ensure it’s consistent
with the country's constitution.
This court has 15 judges, and it serves
as the main check on the ruling party.
It’s supposed to function as an independent
branch of the government.
But upon taking power, Law & Justice
started to erode that independence.
They refused to swear in several judges
who had been appointed
by the previous government,
and replaced them with judges
who would be loyal to them,
including the Tribunal president,
who has the ability to determine
which judges hear what cases.
And of the judges they have appointed legally,
many are actually fellow politicians,
further compromising
the independence of the court.
This has created a tribunal in which
14 of 15 judges are aligned with the ruling party.
And the legitimacy of several
of them is widely disputed,
both in Poland and internationally.
This version of the court has never
decided a case against the ruling party.
"The fact that this Constitutional Tribunal
is acting on the behalf of the political party
is just the opposite of what
the Constitutional Tribunal should do."
It was under these circumstances
that Law & Justice sought a new ruling
from the Constitutional Tribunal
on the country’s abortion laws,
that would eliminate one of the three bases
for legal abortion:
Severe fetal abnormalities.
And while it might seem like that
would only prevent some abortions,
fetal abnormalities are the reason
for 98% of abortions in Poland.
In other words, without
technically banning abortions,
the change would make them
virtually impossible.
Nearly 80% of Poles
disagreed with this change.
But on October 22nd, the Constitutional
Tribunal ruled in its favor:
That the overwhelming majority of abortions
in Poland were unconstitutional.
The ruling brought Poles back into the streets,
and in much bigger numbers than in 2016.
"These protests are really different from
what we've seen for the last four years,
because there are thousands and thousands
of young people attending these protests,
organizing these protests,
and also, these are the most grassroots,
independent protests that we've ever had."
In the face of the protests,
the government has delayed taking the steps
that would make the ruling official.
As of this video, it’s unclear when,
or if, they will.
But these protests are as much about
how this ruling came together,
as they are about the ruling itself.
MARTA LEMPART: "It started with abortion.
Now we fight for freedom, for everything."
For the rule of law."
Outside of Poland, the world has noticed.
International organizations have stopped considering it a full democracy.
And the changes to its legal system have put
Poland’s European Union membership at risk.
30 years ago, Poland enthusiastically
embraced democracy.
Today, its ruling party is trying to rig the
country’s democratic institutions in its favor.
And it's the people
who are fighting to protect them.
"Despite the fact that this government
is responsible for destroying
all the democratic tools
that we have in our Constitution,
you still have the nation,
the citizens in this country,
who carry on the democratic values."